[Music]
big n dri on the market 13 years
now but i had no idea
it would become something that we
would also like my name and alain
amount of maintenance call kiala yum
yum
and so i'm located at the les market
children in paris so one of my
specialties
is the fresh galette the galette is in
fact a savory pancake
it's buckwheat flour and like a
little
big hall anne dieu
tomatoes basil raw ham and
great parmesan so once the
ingredients of a you make a folding of the
pancake he actually went to present
like a bouquet that the end of happiness
dirty taste of a freshness
yum yum cio yum
[Music]
me j  I took the bar which is
traditionally Chinese I
brought them here to France and we
turned it into a fight
my name is clear my restaurant is
called little bao b it is located
in the heart of paris at châtelet les
halles
so here  the specialty did not
hohberg a match  to the color of the bottom to the
match quite clearly from the match to
given that the match in the winter we put the
bread at the bottom oha leather in the
steamer
we put the chicken to fry then that is to
say the sauce the salad  the meat the
cheddar and closes and its ready to eat
a soup there we present my culture
on the one hand of its bread it's like
biting into a cloud in fact the
way the chicken marinates it's really
still flavors that come  from back
home it really makes you travel in we go
Asian flavors
me I grew up here I'm
from China and what was really
interesting was really mixing to
merge the two worlds
[Music]
the attackers it's very  traditional
this minister is there because our way
of eating a sandwich we will say I am
daniela so our restaurant is
called he knows it he is a citizen in the
9th arrondissement in bayer founds our
specialty here birth and patac
have so we  going to say it's a  kind of
salty sandwiches actually the
plantain banana we'll say that's the bread
we take the plantain banana
after we take buildings are in the
group after we call it ti we're going to
fry it twice after we find the
chicken or or the beef the  salad and
sauces and also fresh cheese of course
it's very important the cheese the
pods and it's a thumb or salty meadows
it's quite crispy live a
shot away from home
the thigh and it's very important so
we
started peas at 1014 because you actually want to
share sewing come and
treat among the pool like pasta
to compare your baby so note that if
Lebanese cuisine was announced and in
particular the gypsies and were the
first to implement them  in paris in 2002
my name is worse than at barrels the
gypsy is a family business which
is often found 8o at the intersection
of rue rambuteau and rue
quincampoix in paris so our
specialty suddenly  the
gypsy galette and attacks so
suddenly the base of the zadar galette it will
be a sesame seeds of olive oil
and the sumac we will put
directly on the oven know the
traditional oven know is rounded for the
distribution of the  heat
once it's cooked you can add
after a few ingredients including
vegetables slow and sharp tomatoes
as well as chrome bones of the subscriber
or cheese as the cheese will be
long
so it's a dish that  we eat earlier in
the morning so it's a salty dish in fact
the taste of time is very present
lately for a few years in
france there is a great interest in
lebanese cuisine and then also the
street food side that we are trying to put
en avant un fin
[Music]
normally we don't touch french cuisine
but we wanted to try
my name is narry and i opened the
small roles of paris with françois as a
couple we are at the corner of rue paul
along and rue montma  rtre in paris
our specialty here is the cordon
bleu which we have revisited in a format that
is eaten by hand first frankly the
meat
then we garnish them with the
leave cream then the smoked breast
then we  the roll we put it in film
to take the shape
then it is breaded and fried and
crispy both creamy and fatty
normally the street visits dishes which
have been made in sharp decline his friend and
we wanted to put it to
everyone's disposition is so much more
popular in the street so we
tried to do something
different to surprise the French is
revisited to my popular dish
my habit of eating for reason
[Music]